[Music]
it's no secret that
in any game people love to watch
winners lose every single player talked
about revenge
against skt they got it faker
is destroyed it doesn't matter if it's
faker
fabian the entirety of astralis or the
awe-inspiring
underdog og dominance eventually breeds
a community hunger for downfall
especially if the team on top is flexing
it
this is just fountain farming
you got it this is soul breaking see
it's one thing if whoever's dominating
your esport is also humble
the darling of the scene who looks as if
they simply
stumbled into success but it's something
else entirely if the dynastic
dominator is also well a bit of a dick
now coldzera up against then fallen
we'll have to watch his teammate come
out victorious and the
vm comes through with a tea bag as well
but of all the saucy and uncivilized
stompers ever to clap cheeks and
counter-strike
none have riled up the community quite
like csgo's
one and only wonder child i present to
you
yes for jw vexel the so-called
prodigal pig op god whose infamous
attitude didn't just help his team
become one of the greatest
ever but turned him into the game's
single
most bullied superstar so what exactly
did one of cs go's
greatest all-time operas do to invoke
the wrath of the community
and how has he channeled his
unsportsmanlike toxicity
into something hilarious and well kinda
wholesome
so [ __ ] easy what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is
now in order to understand why my boy j
dubs has
long been regarded as the biggest douche
in cs go
we need to go back in time to when he
was but a wee
wonder lad you see back in the day jw
was a lesser known 1.6 prodigy but once
he made the move to global
offensive he really began to make a name
for himself
and jw what a patience coming out he's
just spotting them he's gonna grenade
instead of the pistol oh my god
and there's jw with the one two triple
oh my god
that is how it starts beautiful play
that was really really really patient
and smart
this is a pretty important round epsilon
are they gonna keep on where they left
off from the eco round doesn't look like
it jw now in a one on two
takes down one and can he get the other
one he will do it
that's a huge pledge by jw aside from
his absurd mechanics
the thing that set jw apart was his raw
unhindered aggression you see in spite
of his age
jw was overflowing with confidence
he was the kind of player who thrived on
making
big dick plays because he knew that he
was better
and wanted you to know it too jw only
will catch guardian guardian trying too
aggressively to
peek into the middle to get the kill on
schneider and that really does not pay
off
once again guardian gone down early in
the round here kuchar is going to take
down flusher
so an important return kill back to a
4-4 jw looking up here he's got to get
the kill
and as angel gone down this is really
really intense right now
dosha he's feeding it right now he's
done a lot of damage to jw
and burke he might just have won the
round for his team oh when he's gonna
keep spraying
jw will take him down back to a two on
two schneider missing a shot
but this bomb is still not being planted
20 seconds left oh
just oh and actually jw gets that that's
a quad kill
an ace in fact for jw i didn't even
notice
jesus christ how did that happen
eventually jw's jaw-dropping talent
led to him being signed by fnatic with
the organization hoping that the
prodigal swede would be able to help
take down
cs go's greatest team ninjas in pajamas
a roster that jw was all too familiar
with
so um they missed that opportunity to to
maybe get an easy kill for flowering
here and now jw on a one-on-one
and he will miss the shot and go down to
his sister what's behind him is
unfortunate but it was a great effort
but jw and his compatriots were
determined to get the better of the get
right gang and
come the overtime of a fateful group
stage matchup at dreamhack bucharest
2013
fnatic finally got theirs fnatic may
have just
done it here in the group states they
might have upset them jw's left but look
at the clock ticking away he doesn't
have much hp
though if he gets into the duel he gets
it and there you have it
gg is called except at first
they didn't you see nip disputed the
clarity of the overtime rules being
enforced by the admins which resulted in
them being granted
a restart stealing away fnatic's
hard-earned victory
now as you can imagine fnatic weren't
particularly
happy about this and after beating nip
once again
in the overtime remake jw decided to
make his displeasure known
to everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
so why was this such a problem well for
starters
his swedish obscenities were directed at
get
right a figure who the cs go community
had
nothing but love for secondly he refused
to shake
hands look being a sore loser
is bad being a sore winner
that's something else entirely from this
point on
fnatic were essentially regarded as
disrespectful little shits with jw
taking the brunt of the community's
backlash and their status as the scene's
antagonists only grew when they toppled
nip again
later that year at cs go's first ever
major
all schneider in there and jd all he has
to do is just wait and buy time
and there it is they win it and look at
them
even khan jumping up one of the most uh
composed people i think in
counter-strike
complete celebration what a victory and
how they deserve it lupus
i mean we did say it fanatic they could
take the victory
they just did it dreamhack winter 2013
champions
you've got them right here on your
screen now it's important to understand
that
at the time the video actually hadn't
been that widely disseminated since cs
go had yet to
really take off fnatic fell off at the
start of 2014
and only after making some very
important roster changes midway through
the year
did they begin to look strong again and
then in 2015
cs go exploded in popularity fnatic got
really good and they kicked off the
greatest
most soul-destroying dynasty their game
had
ever seen and olofmeister playing it so
safely they know
that they have it if sis gets one and
he's back on it he's got the kitties
holding it down i'm not sure there's
enough time
fanatic danny do it
ladies and gentlemen your esl one
cavalieta champions are fanatic
i don't think there's any chance flusher
looking to end this
it's gonna be a third title for fnatic
they win a third major championship in
global offensive
now to be fair there were a lot of
reasons that
one might not especially like fnatic
back in the day
from controversial boosts to olaf's
burning defuse dance
to their bm use of both quadruple ops
and
tec-9s and cheating allegations
surrounding their players
fnatic didn't shy away from the
limelight these [ __ ]
laughed in the face of their critics and
they could because they were just
that damn good and there you go perfect
timing there by apex and now jw decides
to go pushing through apex has that
white oh my god
they light up two for one jw
only jw five kills
and the dream is alive and it was then
right as all of these new cs go fans
were trying to figure out who these
bullying bad mannered swedes actually
were
that the video began to resurface and jw
basically became the poster boy for all
of his
roster's douchery now in the community's
defense
jw was kind of a pain in the ass
throughout his whole career he'd always
had this
wacky way of turning what looked like
brain dead idiocy
into disrespectful works of art uh
fnatic
still trying to just stabilize that bank
account being some close rounds it's
gonna be pronounced
onto the famous there's still jw with
that off awp though he's going on
shortly he's boosted up
going for the aggressive pick and
actually goes all the way towards
suicide and gets a huge hedge on the
garage in there
and cajun taking a fight at long gonna
hit the leg shot there on flusher
and has to immediately fall back with
jade he wants this madness he's picking
up behind the lines he's going to get
the kill on cypnex
and runs away and that has to shake tsm
they have to be shaking their heads and
thinking the only person
in this whole game who would have done
that was jw
there it is a quick challenge there from
jw once again wants banana under control
oh i guess the second connection what is
this
jw that's beautiful stuff
oh my god
it looks like jw's just gonna go on a
mission he's desperate to show that this
is a viable choice you know he does
through the smoke pascha takes a shell
to the chest
it looks like do all the work for him or
not and snacks does pick that one up and
gw finds his second surely not a third
as he's desperately gonna be no no dear
i worry about matchmaking now we're
gonna be seeing a whole lot more sword
off
but as with most things the internet
took their disparagement of jw
way too far since jw couldn't be stopped
on the server his detractors felt the
need to attack him outside of it
thus a vicious vitriolic meme began to
take off
one that ridiculed the opera for
apparently
looking like a pig yep piggles are you
in any way related to jw
like maybe his younger brother is jw pig
why you asking first look his nose
really look like
pig's nose and now he is licking his
mouth i starting to suspect that jw
is a really pig maybe he have pig's army
and
they want to take over valve and gaben
and start the pigs revolution to gives
pigs rights remember the code oink oink
wow from reddit threads to twitch chat
coffee pastas
to [ __ ] posts made by those swamp
creatures who post on the hltv forums
a shamefully large chunk of the cs go
community made it their mission to tear
down one of the biggest
superstars their game had ever seen this
is jw
beyond the snout although i am a pig
i do have more money than most people in
fact i can actually probably buy your
house buy your mom and [ __ ] your [ __ ]
there is not much you can really do in
cs except for cheat and win
as much money as you can so you could
buy an empire to the story of the world
by itself
it didn't matter that the handshake
incident had taken place
two years prior when he was an immature
kid
or that he'd apologized for it profusely
on several occasions
he'd bred a legion of relentless
resentful
idiots who were determined to make him
pay for his success
the issue is that no matter what he did
a sizable portion of the community
wasn't going to allow jw to redeem
himself for his
past offense and since the tearing down
of his image
showed no signs of slowing down he did
the only thing he could
rise above it yeah that's a real man
boobs boys that is better than
all the boobs you can find on twitch
right now
and i'm not even using cleavage as the
vitriol
became increasingly vehement so too did
jw's efforts at evading it
even as fanatic's era started fizzling
to a close
their infamous opera remained as
confident as ever
i love this the gangsters are behind me
like if i say one wrong word right now
it's like
game over how you guys feeling going
into this semi like jeez
like jeez straight up g's i don't even
know if we need to do the rest of the
interview at this point do you guys feel
good that you got a bit of a warm up in
this morning by playing that lower
bracket game that decider game
yeah i knew this was gonna happen and
after serving an
unsuccessful eight-month stint on
godsend
jw and several of his teammates returned
to fnatic
only to find that they were worse off
than before it's
devastating for us you know but at the
same time the the result looks so
so insanely bad but we still feel that
it's not as bad as it look you know
because we we lose to
we lose to the best teams this gave the
community an excuse to [ __ ] on jw
even harder which led him to stoke the
fires from time to time
so much [ __ ] enjoy brother
the thing is the dude was never deterred
from being a dick
because that's how he expressed himself
and he wasn't going to let an onslaught
of bullying change that
i get [ __ ] out aimed by get right
i'm playing major he's in a [ __ ]
minor
i shouldn't lose this
i lose a clutch versus get right man
2018 how and
god knows even some of his peers took
cheap shots at
this guy's gonna try to knife me he's
[ __ ] big
microphone muted i'm streaming
really yeah
but to his credit jw never backed down
he also never got mad he got even
made welcoming
see that's the thing about jw there's no
denying that he's not
everyone's cup of tea but for all the
[ __ ] he gets
he owns it completely now that's not to
say that he's abandoned his natural bm
inclinations altogether
you may have noticed that over the years
jw's developed a bit of a reputation for
knifing people despite being a black
hole of negative criticism
he's never lost his penchant for well
prodding people
what the [ __ ] and always you're gonna
bring out the knife oh i can't believe
you've done this
what's more that proclivity came to a
head at the
end of 2019 and into 2020 when he and
his teammates became
one with the [ __ ] knives and started
stabbing dudes like it was nobody's
business
it became such a meta that fnatic even
dropped some blade themed
merch in their honor no he's just gonna
get the money he's gonna find him
multiple knife multiple kills three
thousand bucks baby
one i gotta get a second
whoa let's go that is so
you guys still lose the rounds the crazy
thing is that was also around the time
that fnatic began to
skyrocket their way back to the top of
competitive counter strike
it felt as if after several years of
mediocre finishes
jw had been humbled a little bit had
mellowed out as a result
and was regaining his confidence i think
i'm starting to improve like people
starting to talk about the old jw but
i would say that this is the new jw
right i'm playing a lot more with rifles
i'm i'm
at least in my head trying to do more
smart things maybe it doesn't look like
that but
this has gone very well so far can they
stick the landing jw swatson
absolutely he did and he's going to try
and go above oh
does he ever get right down he might
deny that
he got it he just got out of the last
swing boom is dropped at jw somehow
finds lacro
what a shot up close what a play overall
experience reigns supreme
and sure he did it by injecting a little
bit of toxicity into his play
but at the end of the day there's
nothing wrong with that contrary to
popular belief
bm isn't always a bad thing it enlivens
esports
helps to develop rivalries and it just
makes everything a
hell of a lot spicier device
and the nade gets it done on to the
defuse and astralis
oh are we in the kitchen right now oh
baby
he's going back he's already dead before
device leave him alone
astralis they're going to take this
smack oh he's going back in leave him
alone device
come on man look it's no secret that
esports can be an
awful inhospitable place to come up in
and while he's definitely conducted a
few
master classes in being a [ __ ] disturber
the thing that jw will be remembered for
isn't a denied handshake it's for
teaching
all of us how to be comfortable in our
own skin
for reminding us that with
self-confidence comes a
swagger that no amount of hate can
hinder
whether you like him or not jw is a
genuine badass not because he's a bully
but because he's learned the hard way
how to be at ease with who he is
to admire himself above all else
in the healthiest and most honest way
imaginable
of course he can get a little carried
away with it sometimes
but that's okay that's who he is
and damn if he isn't proud of it
[Music]
jesus oh jesus [ __ ] christ
accidentally opened
you play just [ __ ] off there we go
absurd mechanics the thing that
oh my god technology is against us bro
[ __ ] robots are rising up
the [ __ ] robots are rising up you
know it hasn't been playing so much cs
go lately that [ __ ] you play is
getting mad
it's jelly it is [ __ ] jelly dude and
it should be